let's talk about where we're at uh
externally right so it's not just the
democrats are
are terrible with domestic policy let me
show you the story we got right here
from newsweek
russia china iran warned u.s must not
intervene in cuba that's right don't you
dare united states intervene in cuba
because
russia and china and iran have have said
so because russia would never intervene
in cuba
oh for sure there's no history of that
remember when the u.s surrendered to
iran
a couple about two years ago some small
ships were forced to surrender so
gunships yeah um i was in the navy the
day that happened
and seeing that image
of my my fellow sailors in in the same
uniform
that i know i was i was in um in the
pacific when that happened they were in
the gulf
and we we were serving in similar
communities put it that way so
like i you know they were i was like one
degree moved from some of those guys
and at that time you know we were still
at
on edge with north korea we're certainly
always on edge with china
it would not have taken much to see
people i knew or you know various
missions to
you know kind of see myself in that
position and thinking that
you know that image right of american
sailors on their knees with their hands
behind their head
to iran of all countries to iran and to
not have a secretary of state
and a president who were immediately
getting on television or picking up the
phone
and saying well this was true no no that
was
that was obama 2019 was when we had the
surrender
when which turn are you talking about
i'm pretty sure it was two years ago
i'm talking about the one in 2016. what
was what happened in that one year 2016
that was the one where they were held
for a couple of days in
in the gulf um and they actually were on
their knees hands behind their heads
and is the one where you were in the
mediterranean tim oh no you're right
you're right 2016.
yeah that was that was january 16.
you're right wow um what was the story
by the way were they
sailing too close out of international
waters they went to iranian water
there is an island called farsi island
in that's
essentially in the middle of the gulf
which so the the gulf is split right now
right so there's
there's um international waters but then
when you get into
uh what a country is called in their
economic exclusion zone
that would essentially be considered our
iranian waters
however this island which is in the
middle
is an iranian island so they have
sovereignty over that so there is an eez
around that island as well and uh their
ship i believe
in the official report it came out they
actually ran out of fuel because the
the junior officer on there did not
didn't actually calculate the fuel that
they would need for the journey they
were going from
the northern the northern gulf all the
way down to bahrain
and they didn't compute it correctly et
cetera et cetera right it's supposed to
be the swing and then you go around the
island
run out of fuel drift into the waters
get picked up but i said hey
and they say hey you're invading our
waters and they say oh excuse me this is
just you know it's a big mistake with
huge understanding
nope this is this is a u.s invasion but
you look at the response now
this is why when you when you said it
was trump said no no no if this would
imagine trump on twitter
right if the iran tcc if the iranian
revolutionary guard
had picked up some of our sailors and
even had even considered
getting close right we are this is trump
by the way who actually did just
straight up
merck and iranian general like the
leader right of of their
um of their force the cuds force which
is like their it's kind of like they're
still team six in many ways
uh but but far beyond that because
they're terrorists as well um
obama i mean we're so sorry we're so
sorry
what do you think the response from this
administration has been following uh
these threats from you know communists
i mean iran you know russia and china
sure but uh what did gen zaki say she
refused
gensaki refuses to admit communism is
the reason behind
cuba's freedom protests and joe biden
others in his administration said it was
about
coven they won't actually confront the
issue
they won't actually speak to the public
honestly about what's going on in cuba
so this is actually scared
this is actually a situation where uh
you know biden who you know and i i'll
give him some advice i don't think he'll
take it but
if he wanted to be smart this is a
chance where you could stand
up for us leadership for the hem this
monroe doctrine this
is excuse me this is the caribbean right
this is nowhere near china this is
nowhere near russia this is our backyard
you don't tell us what we're gonna do
here right
that's not how this works right you
could have that and that by the way
that that used to be u.s policy going
back democrats republicans that was not
a partisan issue that was we yeah yeah
we are going to pay attention to what's
going on in our backyard
because it is in our national strategic
interest to do so right because that
actually matters that's why guantanamo
bay
is our oldest overseas um institution
overseas military installation
that we have since 1898 and i've
actually walked those trails
uh the way the rough riders went in um a
lot of that base
you know you can actually see you know
kind of walk through the battles that
took place
during the spanish american war it's
kind of amazing just to be able to walk
in those footsteps
but you know for him to not just stand
up
for being the leader of the united
states and
act like a great power right it really
goes to show you
that how much that you know it's it's
almost like the you know
biden's personal decline almost
parallels the way that he's putting
america on the path to decline you know
this here's here's the analogy i use
it's like
the dad who gets bossed around at work
and is
feeble so we go home he goes home angry
and beats his wife because she can't do
anything about it right
not strong enough to stand up to those
who are actually causing us problems
the biden administration has a really
easy time of condemning its own citizens
the p 75 million people voted for trump
they're the bad guys
but russia china and iran oh better
better
better uh uh you know right they would
be great if you were if you were walking
around the wrong place at the capitol at
the wrong time
and you know i say this is somebody who
was was physically there on constitution
avenue watching as this all took place
right you know i knew and i said this on
air on one american news at the time i
said there are going to be people
showing up
a quarter of the way back or a third of
the way back there i have no idea
they're just going to walk up and see an
open door and say oh i guess i guess
this is open
i i guess they're like or someone's
holding the door open after holding it
open i guess i can just walk in right
you can be held without charge you can
be ha
and and by the way held for for
peacefully and
it's essentially trespassing whatever
you're doing right right none of the
rhetoric actually matches
in many cases with the charges that are
being that are going on but you'll be
held without bail
which is a complete gross violation of
the constitution you can be you can have
your you can be fired from work you can
have your
your personal funds and your banking
your d bank all that stuff's going on
entire family in texas
was just arrested and i was looking
through the charges there's not even a
including a minor a minor member of the
family was arrested
no violent acts whatsoever so that's joe
biden when it comes to
his own citizens right his own
constituents and so
we have a really interesting situation
right now where it almost feels like
he doesn't treat those people as if they
are citizens of the united states and he
is their president
right it's almost like he kind of thinks
well those guys are trump supporters
so i can treat them differently than i
would treat
a regular us citizen who's all of us
this is what people need to understand
in this country joe biden has not been
speaking to you this entire time
that's what's really fascinating you get
these conservatives who are like oh i
can't believe joe biden said that it's
crazy it's like bro he's not talking to
you
when joe biden came out was like we
might need another lockdown in this
country
taxes in florida had already reopened he
wasn't talking to you red states
when he comes out and says all these
things he is not talking to you he's
talking about you
they don't like you they hate you and
republicans conservatives
disaffected liberals political homeless
idw whatever you are you better
recognize that
they look at themselves as the the
correct
the mainstream the appropriate and
anyone who deviates from that group is
an outside
other extremist so you could be i mean
this is really what cultivates
authoritarianism is made of i have a
great example of this um and it's not
biden
and this this is why what makes it so
perfect it was um
um who is that i was on to uh wendy na
joshua and uh so so she's the
she's um a cnn i think she's put her as
a medical medical analyst right she's
actually the former
president of planned parenthood they
never mentioned that right but she has
this comment and it's so
illustrative of this mentality and it so
perfectly uh
defines what you're talking about
because she says you know
we need to make life harder for the
unvaccinated
we need to uh make there be penalties
for for them going through this we need
to and i'm not even talking about
necessarily focusing on on her vaccine
comments but
and which of course a lot of people
talked about they've gone over it yet
but
when she says we who is she talking
about
when she says we need to do this you're
not you're not a member of government
you're not elected to anything you're
you're a cnn contributor
and yet you're acting as if you have
state-like
power over and that is why i use this
term that i've
started to put it into uh the colloquial
parlance and i've introduced i call it
the overstate
right and this it it sort of combines
this idea of
the sovereignty of the the us government
right and state governments but also the
connection with the media with academia
with social media et cetera silicon
valley wall street
this idea that there is so when she's
saying we are
talking about the party right the party
right against party members
yourself to be brainwashed in the moment
who's who is the the
american shadow communist party we'll
call it that we is a very powerful word
and that it's a cult building mechanism
yeah and i and i noticed that nobody is
bringing up the fact that she just keeps
using it over and over we need to do
this we need to set these in place you
know we need to have these
when uh why are you saying we right and
it's also otherwising because it's we
versus you right it's us versus that
when i listened
when i see the things that joe biden is
posting let me see if i can uh pull up
something specific
there's a video i tweeted here we go
biden said actually i'm gonna play it
i'm just gonna play the video
is it not working we can't oh i muted it
that's the problem
i'm like why is there no sound coming
out oh i turned the sound off we do a
little tick now do you remember
there we go you ready it's no longer
just about who gets to vote
or making it easier for eligible voters
to vote
it's about who gets to count the vote
who gets to count whether or not your
vote counted at
all it's about so there's that's only 16
seconds i don't know the full context
but
assuming that is uh close enough to the
context
you know he's talking about voting laws
in georgia new laws right the new laws
uh this country is already in divorce
i mean seriously when that woman on cnn
says we
need to do x she's not she's not calling
you
we she's not referring to you the people
who are watching the show
she's saying you're outside this when
joe biden says it's no longer about who
gets to vote
it's about who gets to count the vote or
something that effect he's basically
saying it doesn't matter
what is he talking about where's the
context of that
they're claiming republicans are trying
to strip away the right to vote when in
actuality it's the democrats who are
doing it
okay and so he's saying it's not just
about
paraphrasing well i you know i guess who
gets to count it because he's arguing
that the republicans will count it
incorrectly
can i just say though i and i got to say
this i got to be clear we're going to do
a little fact checking around here thank
you jack
as i was driving up here and you know
we're not gonna docks but we are in
is somewhat rural area i did not see
a single fedex kinkos on my entire drive
here
and kamala harris yeah gotta say i think
she's right on this one
no kinkos even though they went out of
business 15 years ago not a single
kinkos
did i she said kinko's she actually said
kingcode out of business for 15 years
yeah well they were it's fed up yeah so
fedex bought them out but even still
like she said
kinko's that's like that's unless kitty
city we've had
a lot of people talk about peaceful
divorce in this country
and i'm not a fan because i don't want
to see china take over like we need
american unity american culture we need
to have a strong comeback but a lot of
people have said
let me people divorce let me ask you a
question yeah how many presidents do we
have right now
how many presidents of the united states
do we have right now i don't know what
you mean by that
like obviously we have one we have joe
biden right we have joe biden but
do you think that there are people who
at this point
just see him so illegitimate that they
just don't view him as the president
they would view but this is not this is
not biden or trump
this is 2016 when people said trump is
not my president
right you that's exactly where it
started where
there were uh and russians have millions
and you can go by the way
joe biden he gave he you have the clip
he said there but there was another clip
where he said
you know this is not what that's not how
we do things in america
you win you lose and then you go on
you don't you don't keep whining about
it and then i'm like joe i'd take
two seconds and run a twitter search on
his own account
and he says uh the the 2016 election was
interfered with by russia they've
undermined our democracy
right he said it right you know but it's
it's right in your own words
in your own words you said essentially
that donald trump didn't win
because of russia so you were saying he
was an illegitimate president
like just like months ago when joe biden
democrat pundits cnn begin referring to
themselves as we which excludes you
you need to recognize what that means is
happening in this country
already it is very obvious that there
are two clearly distinct groups
one currently has the power of federal
law enforcement and they are using it to
crush
dissidents like little old ladies
there's that video where the cop opens
the door for the little old lady
arrested charged some of these people in
solitary antifa free to go
it's very obvious where we're at right
now when joe biden comes out
and he says like they're basically
saying repeatedly
we not us and the we as a reference to
democrats and the party members and not
anybody who who opposes them or any
americans
he is not a president for this country
he is a president for a faction
you can use the word we uh for everybody
like i think we need
decentralized free software social media
and i'm not talking about a group of us
i mean
of course of course but when she said we
need to make life hard for the people
who aren't back yeah so we use it
very quickly in her context she's
referring to we
as a select group of people how they are
going to
control and punish punch she
specifically is talking about
punitive measures yeah for and not even
to get into that issue
but punitive measures for people who
have decided not to opt into
your preferred preference we are going
to take puny again
there are people who are pro-vaccine who
have danced and sang
at the at the at the uh uh advent of
mrna vaccines
who are told by their doctors for
pregnancy reasons for allergy reasons
you are not recommended to get this and
they're saying make their lives harder
or is when are hearing autoimmune
disease that that apparently some people
have uh
this fda announcement that's right
that's why i i'm i'm so
uh some of the people did by like
door-to-door vaccination because you
gotta you have it like
you go to a doctor they give you a list
you check off do you have all
they give you a huge list of ailments
and they're like check out right right
because the doctor looks at and goes oh
man we can't prescribe you this
antibiotic because you have ex
syndrome but a guy going to your
doorstep they're not going through this
at 7 11 at bars i don't want to get in
that whole debate the point is
they're not talking about when she said
we she was referring to a group of
people
who are ex-governmental or extra
governmental who
somehow have the ability to implement
policies and
and and enforcement over everybody else
who is
she or the people on cnn to assert that
they have the ability
to even enforce non-laws over people but
he's not here
who are not part of that here's the
essential truth they do have that power
right they do they know it they know
they do and they and when she says that
and doesn't get any pushback by from any
and you can see there's three people on
at that point
no pushback whatsoever because they all
have that power
because they know they're in the
driver's seat and they know that they
are part of
and there isn't a name for it and that's
why i'm i'm coming up with an i'm
overseeing this title the overstate
because they know that they are a part
of that influence network right of those
competing interests of these
in many cases cnn's owned by a
multinational company
right so we know that they are part of
that group
that is in power and they know that they
can wield that power
over others and in this moment
there's no check there's no check on
that power thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you